the release of American basketball star Brittney
Greiner who's been held in Russia on drug charges
since February is Raising new concerns over
what can be described as hostage diplomacy
a release was part of a prisoner swap for
notorious Russian arms dealer Victor bout
who was serving a 25-year sentence in the U.S
but there are questions about why former U.S
marine Paul Whelan who has been in a Russian
prison for four years was not part of the deal
Christina raffini is at the White House with
the latest on this Christina good morning to you
good morning Jeff Russian President Vladimir Putin
said this week that he's not opposed to the idea
of future prisoner swaps he wouldn't rule them out
and of course the families of detained Americans
all over the world want the U.S to do whatever it
can to bring their loved ones home but lawmakers
and law enforcement are concerned that this
practice could make Americans more of a Target
it was either Brittney or no one the White House
this week celebrated and defended the return of
WNBA star Brittney Griner to American soil this
was about getting getting Brittney home this is
about getting unjustly detained Americans back
to their families that's that was the focus
it's nothing more it's also nothing less but
the prisoner exchange a one-for-one swap for
international arms dealer Victor bout did not
include American Paul Whelan a former Marine
detained in Russia on Espionage charges for
almost four years I wish that Paul Whelan had
been on that that plane too we've been doing
everything possible to to bring him out a U.S
official tells CBS news that over the summer
Moscow proposed trading Whelan for a Russian
assassin serving a life sentence in Germany
but the U.S had no power to release him and
Germany refused hostile weak foreign Nations
taking Americans prisoner and holding them as
hostages this has to stop and my brother needs to
come home on CBS morning's Elizabeth Whelan said
her brother's captivity is part of a larger
issue in July the state department started
including a D indicator in its Travel warnings
for countries where Americans could be at higher
risk of wrongful detention including Russia and
China we need to solve this problem not just for
my brother but also for Americans in general
who want to travel now in that same interview
as CBS secretary blinken said he's working
with a coalition of about 60 other countries
that are looking to end this practice which is
essentially hostage taking for political purpose
he said they're looking at sanctions Visa bans and
other measures Dana all right Christina thank you